[Musique]
aujourd'hui figurez-vous nous sommes sur
les traces de louis 11 alors j'ai décidé
de vous emmener en indre et loire au
château de jallanges nous sommes sur la
commune de vernoux et qui mieux bien sûr
pour nous faire découvrir les lieux que
le propriétaire de ce château il s'agit
de stéphane ferry balle un bonjour
stéphane bonjour bien alors il paraît
ici à partir de la construction
c'est-à-dire 14,165 c'est ça il paraît
qu ici c'était la volonté de louis 11 le
coeur battant du royaume de france entre
amboise ici vers nous et tour pourquoi
donc pas paris et bien justement c'est
là la vraie histoire vraie de la vraie
histoire de france le roi louis xii
darrois qui boudent paris qui boude son
père qui a des relations un peu
difficile avec son père et qui décide de
changer la donne de nommer tour capital
de france a carrément capital cas de
france tour restera capital de france
pour un siècle mais
d'installer à tours et à amboise le
gouver le siège du gouvernement
et puis il est dit qu'il dessine un
triangle équilatéral
et qu'il trouve le château challenge à
la pointe du triangle avec votre
permission parce que vous allez être
notre guide aujourd'hui nous allons
entrer je vous propose qu'on commence
par le salons en enfilade ken histoire
je crois tout à des histoires
eh bien nous y voilà stéphane ce fameux
salons en enfilade alors on va pas tous
les voir parce qu'il y en a quatre je
crois c'est bien ça elle seulement 4 ça
dans l'enfilade de la renaissance qu'est
ce qu'on y faisait exactement est-ce que
ça avait une fonction alors c'était en
fait des salons de vie
le château avant d'être challenge
n'était ce n'était pas un château à
l'origine est et demeure seigneuriale
demeure seigneuriale effectivement 416
131 il est érigé chaque ligne donc là il
est obligé d'entrer dans un dans une
dans une un protocole et donc de ce fait
de recevoir recevoir une partie de la
société de la bonne société entre
guillemets alors ici tous les invités
tous ceux qui avaient la chance d'être
celui ci pouvait passer danser dans
cette enfilade de quatre grands salons
et puis il ya des endroits où pas tout
le monde d'entrée c'est le cas je crois
de la chambre
gaudin nous y emmener parce qu'elle a
une sacrée histoire une sacrée relation
avec un grand roi de france celle ci
alors la voici la fameuse chambre gaudin
alors elle allie une sacrée histoire
sacrée histoire pourquoi alors chambre
gaudin
en l'honneur d'une des nombreuses
maîtresses de françois 1er marigot d'un
françois 1er qui était juste à côté ils
étaient au moins il était à amboise mais
il se déplaçait beaucoup dans les
châteaux privés autour d'amboise le
coquin n'est ce pas et pas qu'un
chasseur devant l'éternel donc donc
voilà il ay ay si cette chambre avec ce
superbe dit à baldaquin marie gaudin qui
est la grand-mère de gabrielle d'estrées
ah oui gabrielle d'estrées bêta zorica
maîtresse d'henri iv qui est déjà large
à cet incroyable ces faits d'histoire en
fait nous sommes trois châteaux qui
célébrons le berceau de gabrielle
d'estrées comme quoi l'histoire de
france
c'est toujours quand même un petit peu
compliqué en temps c'est ce qui en fait
son charme et son acte aurait autre
chose qui a un intérêt tout particulier
c'est une galerie vous avez la chance
d'avoir ici c'est la galerie et le
besnerais le manoir est elle est là
quelques curiosités j'aimerais que vous
m'expliquer pourquoi elles sont là
taisez vous nous conduisait
[Musique]
c'est un lieu vraiment étonnant que
cette galerie parce que la chose cette
curiosité dont on parlait pas ce sont
des trompe-l'oeil pourquoi des
trompe-l'oeil ici et qui les a réalisés
pourquoi est ce qu'on les a placés ici
qui sont d'ailleurs d'une facture
absolument superbe beaucoup de questions
en fait pourquoi être employé parce que
la renaissance l'utilisent les petites
c'est justement de dire oui les nages
mais utilisions la pierre nous
n'utiliserons dubois a sculpté et là on
est passé à la peinture et là on est à
la peinture nom qu'on donne en fait des
dimensions différentes là nous avons des
vues sur le jardin à la française de
l'autre côté des vues sur la loi donc ça
permet d'aiguiller sans avoir et bien le
coût de la réalisation du jardin à la
française
[Musique]
demain je vous invite en loir-et-cher
nous irons au château de tels ci qui est
un monument typiquement renaissance
belle soirée à demain